when I started making mozzarella my
father was finally able to go back to
Italy and when he came back JFK had this
new thing where you had to put your
fingerprints if you had a green card
when he put his fingerprints he woulda
read I guess his fingerprints of birds
the guys in there
they saw all you're the king of
mozzarella and they let him out he is
Sicilian so he's got no fingerprints
though you might want to watch out my
name is Anna chugga-chugga I'm Madonna
from cos I'm a sailor from 1993 my name
is Carlo koch Otto I'm not your son
mozzarella is the biggest selling cheese
in United States of America I forgot by
how many billions of pounds sell a year
it even surpassed American cheese by
about two three billion why is it so
popular I guess because it really can go
with everything if you think about
mozzarella is essential if you want to
talk about American cuisine American
Tigers you like chicken parmesan veal
parmesan which is really nice Italy but
it's more of an American style and goes
with that comes with pizza so it's a
beautiful summer dish that you can make
casual or formal with a little bit of
tomatoes doors you don't roll it up or
in a sandwich
I think mozzarella the way I describe
its art you're stirring and you blend
you and your mold it and you stretch it
up and give that mozzarella stretch
which everyone sees all over the place
and to me it becomes a canvas it's a
work of art
[Music]
the way we make the material here cousin
mozzarella is so you start with curd if
you're making mozzarella you have to
know the correct card this is just warm
milk make a boil and they separate the
cream from the milk more you know the
curl and more minimal selim anyway we
take the guitar a guitar which is the
string that we take the curl we put it
through the string until we get into as
many small pieces as possible then we
put hot boiling water it's too big hot
foals and then like the third power be a
quarter sometimes you do the two
sometimes three sometimes need to change
your water sometimes laughs is
everything is bad feeling then we drain
it and we put two handfuls of salt then
after that we use it an or to blend it I
like to go clockwise so from 12 to 12
then backwards and then side to side
once I feel that there's that texture
and I feel that it's right to be all
stringed and pulled together I start
using my hands and the order to lift it
up the more of my hands I use the more
milk I'm extracting out that's why when
you lift it up you try to use very
minimal hand contact you want to use the
work in that org so when you pull it up
you want to try to go as high as
possible all night I just want to make
sure it comes down evenly it's not the
most important part of the thing it may
be like for the spectacle of it but you
know it's important to get that stretch
and also seeing how the mochila comes
down from that stretch the pics how it
is it's kind of like with coffee if you
if the sugar goes down and express some
cup of sugar too quick you know the
coffee sucks once we put it down and now
it's time to put the fish and touches
like making a Michelle Fairley rocked it
which is just mozzarella with cow's milk
we have burrata which is made with
stracciatella which is mozzarella
broke into pieces made with banda which
is heavy cream we blend it and then we
stuff it in the mozzarella and we close
it then the Balkan Jeanne's probably the
hardest thing which is the small
materials because you have to knot it
but you have to throw something when
you're knotting it
the water is hot so as you're knotting
it you do as a loop and also comes down
to the cut that cut means everything
it's all about the feel touch and
everyone has their own thing he has his
own secrets I have my own ways to buy I
try to emulate him because he is the
king of my cell my father so I try to
emulate him as best as possible but also
giving some of my
own touch to it too cuz the more you
make it you get your own ideas the more
you touch you see different ways how you
can make it better
this neighbor familiar when I came over
the first time I say like wow I'm in
Italy I see the decoration for the feast
of Eli can really do in Italy a
restorative gonna speak Italian - I was
still missing my country thing I thought
I like this table make you like feel
like you really need them I grew up here
a lot to having you watching my dad in
the 1990s it was mainly all Italian it's
changed now which is good it's brought
diversity but then we saw a lot of
old-school people here still we have a
lot of Italians like my buddy Neil over
here
he's been here for the god knows how
long he'll sell over county's 1917 he
knows my grandfather at seven years this
is Bogardus they've been here for about
a hundred years they're known for making
fresh ravioli fresh pasta stuffed
raviolis this is one of the premier meat
markets it's called Vincent's meat
market bread we've being in my store
today comes from Adele they've been here
for so long I love how they've kept the
vintage look at the sign this is a hair
salon lot of Italian people go even
haven't asked a lot that I think they go
figure right there's always a debate of
what's the real early is it in Manhattan
is it in the Bronx but all I can say is
from from my opinion there is one real
early and that's the Lord in the Bronx
and guys that is Arthur Avenue
I came in from Middle in 1986 and now a
mere 22 years our Lin solver 25 and
there is why I'm do good is because a
lot of what I'm doing they always ask
who is your idol I mean I don't need to
say Derek Jeter Michael Jordan LeBron
James you tell the other guy that comes
from other country and tell me what has
more balls than that to leave his mother
his father everybody make a living and
not just make it here but really make it
here and be successful not because of
money but b6l because he's happy I'm
happy
my mother's happy when you think of what
America represents it's the smell not
your car Chopin he is the American dream
and I couldn't be more proud to call my
father
you